[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Rubeus Hagrid is borrowing from magic
and whether or not his ability to freely
perform magic was ever given back to him
in Chapter four of the Philosopher's
Stone Hagrid visits Harry on his
birthday
finally and delivering Harry's Hogwarts
acceptance letter the same letter that
Vernon Dursley refused to allow Harry to
see after Hagrid arrives he uncovers
that the Dursleys never told Harry about
his parents or Hogwarts or magic or The
Wizarding World outraged he gets into a
heated exchange with Vernon Dursley a
heated exchange that pushed Hagrid to
his breaking point I am not paying for
some crackpot old fool to teach him
magic tricks yelled Uncle Vernon but he
had finally gone too far Hagrid seized
his umbrella and whirled it over his
head never insult Albus Dumbledore in
front of me he brought the umbrella
swishing down to there to point it
deadly there was a flash of violet light
a sound like a firecracker a sharp
squeal and the next second Dudley was
dancing on the spot with his hands
clasped over his fat bottom howling in
pain when he turned his back on them
Harry saw a curly pig's tail poking
through a hole in his trousers when he
did this Hagrid broke at least three
Wizarding laws first of all he assaulted
a muggle a little boy second of all he
used magic in front of muggles and
lastly he performed magic illegally
after casting a spell on Dudley Hagrid
says the following shouldn't have lost
my temper
he said ruefully but it didn't work
anyway meant to turn him into a pig but
I suppose he was so much like a pig
anyway there wasn't much left to do I'd
be grateful if you didn't mention that
to anyone at Hogwarts he said I'm not
supposed to do magic strictly speaking I
was allowed to do a bit to follow you
and get your letters to you and stuff
one of the reasons I was so keen to take
on the job
why aren't you supposed to do magic
asked Harry oh well I was at Hogwarts
myself but I got expelled to tell you
the truth in my third year they snapped
my wand in half and everything but
Dumbledore let me stay on his game
keeper great man Dumbledore
why were you expelled asked Harry it's
getting late and we've got lots to do
tomorrow said Hagrid loudly gotta get up
to town get all your books and that
Hagrid changes the subject when Harry
asks about his expulsion and borrowing
from magic so what's the deal why isn't
Hagrid allowed to perform magic in the
Chamber of Secrets we learn that Hagrid
was expelled from Hogwarts when a fellow
student
none of them Tom Riddle framed him for
opening the Chamber of Secrets releasing
a creature that would go on to kill
Moaning Myrtle when the Chamber of
Secrets is opened for a second time
during the time at Harry's attending
Hogwarts Cornelius fudge arrests Hagrid
for safety sake still uncertain of
hackers innocence as Hagrid is taken
away
he tells Harry to follow the spiders
this leads Harry and Ron to the
Forbidden Forest where they meet Aragog
a giant spider that was once Hagrid to
pet Eriko explains to Harry that it was
not him who killed Moaning Myrtle for
that he did know what did after this
Harry locates the entrance to the
Chamber of Secrets and is eventually
able to prove that it was in fact Tom
Riddle who originally opened the chamber
and released the Beast inside after this
new information comes to surface Hagrid
is released from Azkaban prison and
returns to Hogwarts because Hagrid was
expelled in his schoolboy days he never
finished his education this meant that
he was an unqualified wizard and
subsequently wasn't allowed to perform
magic however given that his name was
eventually cleared however many years
later I began to wonder was Hagrid ever
officially allowed to perform magic
given that he was an innocent man it
would make total sense that his ability
to perform magic would be reinstated
so was it JK Rowling was actually asked
this exact question in an interview with
Southwest news service she was asked
since Hagrid's name was cleared in book
will he ever be allowed to do magic
openly again - which rolling responds he
is allowed he has been allowed to do
magic openly ever since he became a
teacher but because he was never fully
trained his magic is never going to be
what it should be he is always going to
be a bit inept as we know it was the
1993 to 1994 school year that Hagrid
officially became a professor
responsible for teaching students about
the care of magical creatures Hagrid was
expelled in 1943
this means that Hagrid had to wait a
completely absurd 50 years before his
ability to perform magic was reinstated
better late than never I suppose and
that's it for this video if you have any
video suggestions please leave them down
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]